foreign Jeremy Hunt Boris Johnson these
guys will make a fortune you know these
guys make a ton of money it doesn't
matter if they fix the problem and the
economists who advise them okay they're
not going to be multi-multi-millionaires
they're going to make hundreds of
thousands of pounds a year they're going
to be comfortable it doesn't matter if
their advice is wrong
and anyone who does understand can get
paid a ton of money over there so I
think
really what is really happening is the
system is is quite rotten at the core in
in a way that is itself a manifestation
of inequality which is that
why would the general public get good
economists
when the rich are going to pay good
economies two million pounds a year to
work for them you see what I'm saying
it's not inequality doesn't just mean
you don't get a house it also means the
government cannot afford good
the best people in many cases when you
add on to that at a terrible education
system with economics and a massive
outside incentive for anyone good to
leave
it becomes inevitable but I think